this place seems like make-believe or
perhaps the fever dream of a design
blogger no one in their right mind would
build a hotel in a forest and stick the
rooms up in some trees but then again it
sort of fits perfectly ah because this
is Sweden and the treehouse Hotel booze
is sweet its nature fornicating with
functional design and creative thinking
this is the UFO and really this is why
we came to Sweden to get Wi-Fi out here
from Stockholm to the Arctic Circle
Swedes have pumped out dazzling tech
infused products to put a new twist on
what it means to be modern entertaining
and useful on this episode we're going
to find out how this tiny nation ended
up as perhaps Europe's premier
technology power
what's the secret that Sweden figured
out that other countries seem to have
missed because there's no question that
these Swedes are up to weird and
wonderful things want proof we'll check
out a face whopping robot pretty awesome
get up close and personal with a turbine
and that would be kind of equivalent to
a new clock and pound cinnamon buns with
Spotify is Daniel Eck you were going to
clubs down and I was thrown out Bhaskar
Silicon Valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world but
it's being challenged like never before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind my name is Ashley Vance
I'm an author and journalist and I'm on
a quest to find the most innovative tech
creations and meet the beautiful freaks
behind them hello world okay here's what
you probably know about Stockholm it's
beautiful it's full of gorgeous
unassuming people and it's almost
disturbingly clean what you don't know
about Stockholm is that outside of
Silicon Valley it's the world leader in
fostering tech addiction Spotify Skype
and the makers of Minecraft and candy
crush all got their start here
the Swedes these supposedly cool fashion
challenged people know how to tap into
our desires and make simple things we
can't escape I started my journey at
epicenter a nerd lounge located in the
heart of Stockholm any place trying to
establish its tech cred needs a spot
like this people come here to fiddle
with their robots hash out their techno
utopian fantasies over beer and if
they're totally nuts insert a chip
underneath the skin on their wrists that
lets them open the epicentre door hello
dad
my name is Fahad about those robots
my reptile brain is telling me that this
thing is alive and then my intellect
sells me no I know it's just a piece of
plastic and some software we've stumbled
upon something really super interesting
this is fur hat a promising stab at
trying to make mechanical creatures and
computer interfaces appear and act more
like humans hi my name is Ashley hello
Ashley nice to meet you I am a socially
intelligent robot it's nice to meet you
as well
nice shirt thank you we want to build a
system that can interact very fluently
with humans understand their social
signals their emotions their attend
attention States there's a phenomenon
known as the uncanny valley
it's that queasy feeling you get when a
robot or computer interface looks real
but not real enough the brains behind
Ferhat these two hardcore academics
think they're on their way to solving
that problem and making robots less
nauseating we come from a background of
human human communications on how humans
interact with each other is the social
layer that is on top of the typical AI
if they can push the technology forward
Ferhat could end up as the face of Siri
or Amazon's Alexa it might keep lonely
people company do you think I look good
or be the thing you yell at when
checking in for a flight at the airport
can you walk us through like each little
piece that is main piece here she's got
a hat and a wig and a skull and a mouth
as far as robots go fur hats design is
really simple it's as easy as taking a
mask on and off and then the mask is
magnetically attached so you can unplug
the mask and then you can attach the
different masks it's front response to
it and then it needs to be calibrated so
that you can get the right yeah I do
want to see the alien baby what did you
say
there is a facial animation system you
know like the ones you have in games an
animated movie
yeah so it's all software based and then
we use a micro projector to project that
animation onto a master you get very
accurate eye movement gestures facial
expressions lip animation I can look
like a woman and sound like a woman like
an avatar that's level but I think the
world has been really waiting for robots
at home to interact with Tokyo to see
them in a human natural habitat where we
don't see any robots at the moment one
day fur hat might read bedtime stories
to your kid I'd say it's at the
nightmare stage of that journey but the
product has gone on sale for use by
universities which are busy tweaking it
to ensure sweet dreams in the years to
come you were boring why would you say
that to me you would look strange or to
sling insults and handsome TV hosts how
about a beer coming up
I do the fika thing with Spotify as
Daniel a it's not to get for help and
we'll break the Swedish code of conduct
that when I drink it
Sweden's rise as a tech power did not
happen by accident the country's
advanced industrialization is due
largely to Swedish invention like the
dial telephone and to high standards of
Engineering starting in the late 1990s
the government made a huge investment in
broadband laying fiber optic cables
throughout the country then it began
subsidizing pcs so every citizen could
have a modern computer with a superfast
internet connection but this wasn't all
about making a sterile nerd Factory the
Swedes also designed their education
system to emphasize creativity and
experimentation and to mix the Arts and
Sciences one curious offshoot of the
social engineering was that Sweden
created a nation of pirates that
generation of tech infused youngsters
set out to pirate software music movies
anything really and did so with
astonishing skill file-sharing services
like Kazaa and utorrent started here and
so did an entire political party
literally called the pirate party one of
the Pirates was this bald beauty
Daniel lack Iran Hey yes let's see you
back ran utorrent and ended up on the
wrong side of the music labels then he
pulled a 180 and decided to try and
become the music industry's Savior by
starting a new less Deeley company
Spotify it was Swedish simplicity the
turn Spotify into a huge hit people
could find stream and download songs
with such ease that neither consumers
nor the labels could resist the service
almost every morning X stops off at
saternus a trendy cafe in the oyster mom
neighborhood of Stockholm here he
engages in fika a Swedish snacking
ritual that takes place a few times a
day should we dig in
dig in please like him it was good it's
it's um seems more wholesome than like a
Cinnabon yeah so you got it set off on
the path of doing tacking music so
really the only thing that was important
in my family was that you'd learn how to
play music I got a guitar when I was
like three four okay but yeah I got the
computer when I was like five and for me
like in the beginning it was really all
about games just fun playing from that
point I kind of realized like hey these
games are boring how hard would it be to
try to fix the game yeah and so I
started coding games when I was seven or
eight there's some point I it's kind of
amazing that you've been on this
trajectory yeah you know your whole life
yeah I've never had a normal job when I
grew up like I didn't realize how you've
made money starting something yourself
we're investing money or life that was
just the totally foreign concept outside
of Silicon Valley Sweden has the highest
per capita number of unicorns which are
startups valued over 1 billion dollars
there's a tension that comes with all
this new money and fame like much of
Scandinavia Sweden operates under a
cultural code of conduct known as Ianto
law it's a philosophy that demands
people not think too highly of
themselves I was wondering if people
recognize you out on the street um yeah
I mean they do but because this is like
Sweden no one really comes up except if
it's like 10:00 p.m. and they've had a
beer or two cut to 2016 and this way of
living finds itself in conflict with
tech millionaires boozing it up at clubs
and hyping their tight
laughs AK knows the situation as well as
anyone by the time you're 21 I mean you
were a millionaire especially right
because you had sold a couple businesses
and now I'm very well for yourself and
then it sounds like you went through
sort of a period where I don't know if
showing off is the right word but you
were living oh yeah going to clubs and
and I was driving past cars when I look
back to it I'm sort of almost ashamed of
myself because it was like you know it
was today I realized there was a huge
sort of period of insecurity there's a
lot of fun don't get me wrong but it's
it's like not Who I am and I never know
like as an outsider if we make too much
of all this but this idea that you don't
want to stand out and yeah I'm Sweden or
Scandinavia and you do stand out what
yeah when you start making billions
dollars a little hard yeah but it is
changing I mean if you walk around in
the city now like I see like Ferraris
Lamborghinis like there's quite a lot of
that here which is not really part of
what the fabric of how it used to be to
really contemplate yann to LA I took
part in another Swedish tradition known
as standing pensively against a wall
completely aware that I was being
photographed for my own TV show we're
supposed to pull your head
here are some of the rules of yan to lie
you are not to think you're anything
special you are not to think you're as
good as we are
you're not to think you're smarter than
we are you're not to convince yourself
that you're better than we are
you're not to think you know more than
we do not to think you're more important
than you're not to think you're good at
anything not to laugh at us you're not
to think anyone cares about you you're
not to think you can teach us anything
ah
that was refreshing with the
brainwashing portion of the program over
it was time to live a little we decided
to get out of the cold dine at a
traditional Swedish restaurant and then
hit the town
it'll be just gonna be getting yours I'm
Ashley thank you Henrik all right Maria
oh the promise country I'll tell you
this about yah Allah it gives way after
a few cocktails what to mix this with
the lemon and the old smelly I don't
know what it's cold in Sweden economy
fish
yeah it's now we're up steps yeah nah
Jerry that's whatever gets me cuz
they're just yeah my food is that out
and that's when the other part of the
Swedish character the friendly joyfully
lubricated part goes on full display
hey ho vote a snail fun marine attended
go near the end of the night it was time
for my famous disappearing cigarette
magic trick I guess it and my man bun
needs some work coming up I'll find out
where my embarrassing photos live this
is where all the action happens and beat
a turbine named Esther
as vibrant as the startup scene is in
stockholm sweden x' technology muscle
lies in the northern part of the country
had 560 miles up from stockholm and
you'll end up in lou leo a picturesque
city of 70,000 people wedged between the
gulf of bothnia and the arctic circle
for centuries
lou leo has been a cultural an economic
hub of this region but what really has
Lou Leo buzzing these days is the
arrival of Facebook which opened a data
center on the outskirts of the city in
2013 at 300,000 square feet it's one of
the largest computer centers ever built
it's the kind of place you need a bike
and a picnic lunch to explore fully and
while you're on that picnic lunch you
can take a selfie and post it here go
it's nice to see you again I actually
want to come to do thank you and welcome
to Facebook you'll Sjogren's has managed
the operations at the Lully OData plant
since it opened
he offered to show us the guts of this
beastly building
some people think the cloud is actually
a cloud
for others it's an ethereal mystery the
place where your photos and documents
get sucked to and hang out this though
is the cloud
at least the physical manifestation of
it it's thousands of servers and storage
systems working together to hold our
information this is where all the action
happens this is where all our photos are
like this is really where Facebook is
actually running look around see over
there it's a picture of a young Ashley
Vance who thought that going blonde
would be a good idea and that one
it's a lingering poke from your creepy
ex and right there is an inspirational
meme helping lift people's spirits where
does my mom find all these amazing
quotes and because we've built the
infrastructure to be so redundant we can
basically pull any server and it's not
going to affect any end user in in any
negative way so we pull one out here
okay so we're going to take down
Facebook a typical Monday measure but
it's all built to be as energy and
cooling efficient as possible so there
are no fans at all on this one as you
can see they're sort of it's just
working on the pressure difference that
forces here through I think for most
people who've never been to a data
center they're usually like these big
sort of pizza box things with tons of
fans and moving parts going on them and
you guys compacted everything down if
the industry in general started adopting
a lot more of this thinking it could
really change the whole industry and not
just Facebook a couple of corridors
we'll go through a typical data center
relies on massive air-conditioning units
to pump cool air onto tens of thousands
of computers you can't pay for this kind
of wind blowing lucky Facebook is too
hip for that
ketchup it uses cool arctic air to keep
its photo friend and like machines from
melting down this whole place lends
itself to Sweden's meticulous attention
to detail and design the building is an
engineering marvel that treats air like
a pampered Corgi poo the air gets sucked
in cleaned watered and then sent on its
way via physics with the building
pressure pushing the air down onto the
computers since facebook gives away its
service for free this place needs to
operate as smoothly and cheaply as
possible to minimize the cost of each
click off camera you'll readily brags
about Facebook's cheap clicks on camera
Yan Tala we've kind of been dodging
around the point I mean this may be the
world's was the fish power efficient
data center is most likely one of the
most efficient ones damn Swedish modesty
it's not just free cold air that brought
Facebook to the Arctic Circle the social
network also came for the cheap reliable
power produced by Sweden's vast set of
hydroelectric dams
starting in 1910 the Swedes began
building a network of two dozen
hydroelectric dams along the Lulay River
today the dams provide more than enough
power to meet all of northern Sweden's
needs so now we will start to urinate Lu
the river on Lu the river power Rick
Abramson and Kristi Lungren
worked for Vattenfall the energy giant
that runs the dams they were kind enough
to take me on a road trip to see up
close how these amazing machines work
these guys insist that it's wonderful
living in the great frigid north they
can check out the Northern Lights from
their hot tubs spend months in total
darkness and hunt bears and moose so
Rick did you already go moose hunting
this year then the small hunting ground
where I'm caught there's only one grown
up in one cough and the first morning 30
minutes into the hunt they shot the big
one nothing's over and everyone's done
walk me through again like how many dams
there are a long sister will do that we
have 15 power stations along this river
of course with great power comes great
responsibility
and you know stuff to placate people
they care about nature and fish we are
one of the Lord you should have fish
breeders in Sweden to compensate for the
fact that we built all the power
stations because they the settlement
cannot sort of pass through the river
system now so the energy company breeds
sailing yeah we do how many would you
have to put back in for yeah in the Rue
de Rivoli put back close to half a
million every year well it used to take
hundreds of people to run these dams but
today they're controlled by two
easygoing Swedes working in this command
center from here we controlled the
complete river system 15 power stations
and we have two guys here who controls
to go complete River that's what seems
incredible raise the two people would
handle half a country's power yeah you
could essentially turn on a turbine and
shut off a turbine and so today that's
all done through software yeah on the
rest of our journey today we'll get to
go and see some of the absolutely you're
gonna see the biggest one we have in
Sweden and that would be kind of
equivalent to any other block okay yeah
I know we're 90 neutral box
Vonn fall has turbines of all sizes
some of them like this big beauty named
Esther now you see the size of it yeah
George produces much power as a nuclear
reactor there we go this is what you've
been waiting this feels like the seconds
before a shuttle loan it says really
I've been to a couple yeah how long does
it take to get up to full speed here
comes the water
standing next to one of these turbines
when it fires up is one of life's great
organ rattling pleasures the closer you
get the more manly you feel for some 250
cubic meters a second in the courtroom
after getting my organs rattled I
decided to head back to Lou leo and
decompress damn what a day it's been a
long but awesome week in Sweden somehow
we ended up near the Arctic Circle with
a campfire it's our lucky day I've been
to Sweden a few times and this trip
confirmed my previous impressions about
the country
these are pleasant people who are
remarkably good at making things
everyone wants but what's more
impressive these days is the way in
which the Swedes are embracing
technology the people here try harder
than anyone else to find a balance
between striving for a bright future
while living within their means and then
you know cinnamon buns on the next
episode of hello world we go to Israel
where I float in the Dead Sea is a
technique doeth hop in a jet and build a
space laboratory seems hard to believe
that you could do that much science and
something besides
you